Bellagio difficult tournament for you up
to this point but finally you get that
Victory tell us a bit about this game
and especially this moment when you play
C5 this is I believe the seventh move by
number of games in this uh very topical
position how did you come up with this
idea well C5 it's not it's not so
uncommon to play this it's just I think
most people play Bishop B7 first and
then even here like if for example white
played something like Bishop E2 it might
transpose into I play Bishop B7 yes and
it transposes to a line that's been
played a lot already on the line yeah
but it's kind of like to throw
um I put an offbeat which I guess is
what happened and and he played this
move A3 which surprised everybody I'm
sure it surprised you as well probably
it was just like a mechanism to get you
out of the opening yeah I think so I
mean A3 is also a common idea sometimes
to get opponential opening and these
type of lines that have like 20 moves of
theory so it was somewhat logical but
yeah it didn't feel right in this
position
and take us through the critical moments
now this change of structure I really
liked it with the idea of A6 then that
pawn on it looks threatening yeah but it
actually doesn't do that much right you
control it very well yeah it's even if
he managed to hold the pawn like he did
it's he's just trapping his own Queen
and Rook to protect one Pawn while his
King is getting completely opened up so
I think it's a very good trade for me
and one thing that you were mentioning
you were saying that okay sure Rook to
H3 is a bit overzealous but you couldn't
see any alternative moves for him yeah
either I was thinking maybe he goes
Queen B5 but even here I got Rook A7 and
this end game is very comfortable it's
really hard to hold this I think we're
just Wyatt Queen takes yeah Queen takes
another Bishop d8 in the end which is
important yeah okay Bishop d8
that's nice yeah and why is it much more
comfortable for black
Games The Rook on each one I mean all
his pieces are in the first rank still
and with so many weaknesses the B2 Pawn
is a huge weakness H4 is always going to
be hanging yeah and my pieces is I
castle in the next move and all his
pawns are under attack and it's very
hard for him to get everything out in
time yeah so it's about the structure
it's about the fact that he's not
developed it's very unpleasant and
he came up with this idea route to B3
but missed this next move of yours Rook
takes A7 which pretty much takes the
game into yeah completely winning and
yeah right well actually an important
Victory and you actually know Josiah
quite well you both come from the bear
yeah you you guys are good friends
training occasionally together tell us
about uh this uh matchup between here
too I mean it's always kind of difficult
to play a friend because we know each
other quite well we've played multiple
games already so it's also openings Wise
It's hard to like think okay I've
already played so many of these lines
against him what do I really want to
play yeah and okay especially when
you're such a strong tournament you want
to still fight though you're not gonna
like take it easy just because they're
your friend and I think it honestly if
anything it motivates you more to like
try to just like especially me I'm
having a tough tournament I really want
to like hit back hard and luckily I got
an opening where I had the chance to do
that and it worked out how do you find
that balance between wanting to hit back
too hard and you know just not losing
more games
yeah well I think a thing for me is like
I generally like to play aggressive type
of line so I'm like okay let's just try
my luck and
um I like I realized I had to make some
changes with the way I was thinking in
the first two rounds and I was like okay
the best way to do that is keep fighting
if you play more slow and as black most
people like to play it slow and try to
equalize but I I think if I try to fight
back it forces me to like come out back
to my true form and I hope that's kind
of what this game did
excellent recovery for you biology
congratulations guys any questions no
just a congratulations can I have one
quick question congratulations Balaji on
this win I know last year you tied for
third so I understand your Ambitions are
very high I'm curious how much do you
value win with black because it's always
harder to win with black uh do you value
it more than winning with white or what
can you tell us about that I think it's
always much nicer to win with black
because
um it's generally you should be fine
with the draw with block against most
players in this tournament I think and
so it's always nice if you can win but
at the same time I wouldn't say that
it's so important because in this
tournament everyone's gonna become
fighting it's not going to be like this
is not like it's like super top
tournament yet where it's impossible to
win with black and so I think for me
it's slightly better but not too much of
a difference to win with either color
let's win the win is good
wow well done well done I'd like to turn
our attention to the game of Alice